à qui plaisent les chaudes
monsieur je m'appelle dominique j'ai 12
ans ma soeur 14 mai par an 40 et ma
grand-mère 78 l'émission des shadoks
n'amuse personne quel âge faut-il avoir
pour être intéressé par cette émission 3
x 4 de cap 33 59 ans sénatrice des
personnes très intelligentes devraient
me dire des personnes très intelligentes
devraient me dire si ce sont des
émissions pour les enfants les grandes
personnes ou les chats en espérant les
voir disparaître sincère amitié de
marennes c'est pas ma marraine qui fait
ça c'est une lettre qui vient de
marennes
mais je tiens à vous dire que l'émission
les shadoks est marrante pour nous car
j'ai un chat qui s'installe bien devant
le poste et qui n'en perd pas une pluie
qui est pourtant si sauvage
d'habitude le chat ne regardez pas les
émissions ça lui plaisait pas et la
doublette les chats de plus en plus
alors pour moi qu'ils durent le plus
possible pour loi qu'il y en a qui
n'aiment pas les shadoks c'est parce
qu'il aime tant les chiens nous on a
deux petits bas c'est quand ils
entendent le journal télévisé ils
dorment mais quand les chats dès qu'ils
arrivent alors il aboie il n'y a que ça
qui leur plaît mais ma soeur préfère
tout de même
léon zitrone messieurs oui oui oui
l'émission intéresse prodigieusement ma
petite
qui ne perd pas un geste d indigènes
shadoks et semble très amusé son plaisir
fait ma joie merci à aa aa aa aa aa aa
aa aa